[Musique]
le blues est urgentiste bon là c'est pas
vous qui conduisait en ce moment un
monsieur brou non non non vous êtes un
urgentiste mais vous mettez pas votre
ceinture
donc finalement de se triturer donc je
trouve que finalement je trouve que
c'est pas mal finalement parce que même
vous voilà le risque de la ville est là
et c'est pas moi qui vais vous blâmez de
cela préparez vous c'est la seconde
guerre mondiale
je vais faire une salade niçoise comme
quoi vous n'êtes pas prévu moi je t'ai
harnais des terrines ça part en couilles
ce machin je sais pas s'il faut que je
dise quiz mais je crois que je suis en
train de partir en couille il appartient
qu'est ce que tu as sur le mois donc
tout ce que j'ai fait chômage peu oui
alors c'est autant
[Musique]
j'ai dit veux tu m'épouser y est j'ai
éclaté de rire puisque bas nerveusement
c'est un peu la demande que j'aurais
souhaité toute ma vie plus simple que
d'un rebond parloir alain c'était juste
magnifique
si pamela est séduite par la simplicité
de la demande est là malgré tout une
exigence particulière
j'ai simplement dit que si je devais me
marier avec jason statham attendent
devant la mairie parce que sinon je
m'arrêterai pas
mais oui fm dans des eaux
[Musique]
mais qui sait mais qu'est-ce que 6
devant lui des bars qui la jugent
statham au bras sur le coup je dis c'est
quoi il va falloir éclaircir ce point
non mais elle s'arrête quand les
surprises lahoud et on n'a même pas
commencé la cérémonie civile chez déjà
deux des kits des paillettes de la
licorne et jason statham lettre
bizarroïdes oui une 30 300 euros free
qui nous dit star dans l'univers du
tatouage à son corps entièrement
recouvert
même ses yeux sont colorés par lancre
quand il n'est pas dans un salon de
tatouage sylvain 35 ans est aussi
professeur remplaçant en essonne tu as
eu d'abord il a le droit de se tatouer
vous laisseriez vos enfants et les
visiteurs il a trois tacles et chacun a
droit
est-ce qu'il a le droit de se tatouer et
d'aller à l'école comme ça c'est oui la
loi il est prof depuis des années
effectivement il peut y avoir débat
votre apparence est impressionnante
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
parents qui ont peur pour leurs enfants
déjà je tiens à préciser que la plupart
des parents qui se plaignent ce sont les
parents d'enfants que je n'ai pas lu en
classe les parents d'enfants que je lui
en classe tout se passe bien il suffit
de que je sois présente et que
j'enseigne pour qu'on voit que je suis
quelqu'un de normal qui parle un
français châtié et qui fait bien son
métier
si je vous dis j'ai un trou vous
comprenez tout de suite que j'ai j'ai un
trou de mémoire il ne vient pas à
l'esprit que je puisse évoquer mes
chaussettes ma comptabilité ou mes
fesses j'en conclus donc de tous les
trous ils sont nombreux le plus
important le plus grave c'est le trou de
mémoire
la main tendue un homme présente à
manger à un écureuil dans une forêt en
russie tout se passe bien jusqu'à ce
bruit
le rongeur s'arrête alors net il est
comme figé en état d' alerte
et rien ne semble pouvoir le distraire
[Musique]
c'est une micro c'est ce que vous faites
car et d'une longue réflexion j'ai cru
que quelqu'un va me pose souvent sur le
après deux minutes il se calme se remet
à manger brièvement avant de s'enfuir
[Musique]
et si jamais vous mettez quelque chose
de dégoûtant dans votre bouche vous est
pris de nausées et votre estomac se
soulèvent pour l'empêcher d'aller plus
loin il ya quelques temps il s'est fait
enlever les oreilles et là on reparle de
vollard c'était là ça c était un guide
et à combien d'années il ya au moins
basse étant il ya sept ans et ça on
regarde et regarde sur la photo en fait
on pour reparle de lui aujourd'hui parce
qu'il s'est fait enlever le nez donc en
fait il ya plus du tout de cartilage ya
plus rien du tout voilà ça c'est comme
ça qu'il est aujourd'hui mais tout et
tout le temps comme ça et les toitures
que c'est pas un maquillage je vous
assure que c'est pas un maquillage la
dernière étape de la réaction de dégoût
est un geste instinctif de la main
destinés à se débarrasser du danger
[Musique]
voyez choses qui sont beaucoup plus
grave que ça voyait à mes yeux dit les
programmes des bas mais oui de
télévision de fine art je veux dire est
ce que les fines chose mais dans les
émissions se trouve ça tellement plus
grave est que de manger d'unités la sq
avait raison sur une chose les gens se
préoccupent beaucoup trop beaucoup plus
de ce qu'ils mettent dans leur assiette
de co2 qu'ils mettent dans leur cerveau
trouve que c'est l'histoire de ma vie
sont toutes les filles que c'est mon
style je suis pas leur style
mais bon c'est pas grave je me relever
allez
est ce qu'il va nous regarder des fesses
aux ayants droit n'a pas le droit à plus
tard oh la la
la tension marine le pen qu'on appelle
on dirait qu'au début je l'appellerai
dresse un petit message
madame le pen c'est johnny n'a pas qui
est cette année est ce que vous pouvez
me rappeler j'ai vu que vous deviendriez
pas dans une de mes émissions
c'est dommage parce que je voulais vous
inviter dans les boîtes et ya les 300000
bull a gagné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
l'enjeu
publiée deux grandes images avec deux
personnes peu importe leur disposition
twitter choisira d'afficher en priorité
l'homme à la peau blanche dans l'aperçu
c'est ce poste qui a soulevé un problème
dans le système de recadrage automatique
entre mitch mcconnell et barack obama
c'est le sénateur républicain qui est
mis en avant attendez cup qui attendent
[Rires]
depuis cette publication de nombreux
internautes font des tests jusqu'à
utiliser des personnages des simpson ou
des chiens
à chaque fois le même résultat le réseau
social indique qu aucun préjugé racial
n'avait été détecté dans son algorithme
mais des analyses plus poussées vont
être menées bien joué sinon cavej à dire
d'autre rien me dit on tu peux
l'affirmer